but we're going to begin this hour with
the State of the Union speech by
President Biden last night did you stay
up late to watch yep you did this was
the first time that he addressed
Congress since Republicans took control
of the house and you could say he got
some noisy pushback from some GOP
lawmakers
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
[Music]
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
I'll give you a copy of The Proposal
vice president Kamala Harris joins us
now from Washington Madam vice president
it's good to see you I want to get your
take on the good morning the speech last
night I've heard because that is one of
the story lines this morning I've heard
descriptions of heckled rude obnoxious
but the president of the United States
seemed to thrive in the give and take at
points what did you make of the tone
last night in the room
well good morning Gail I'll tell you I
was in the room obviously and I think
that they're sadly tends to be a
theatrical element to that evening as
time has gone on but I think the
president was in command and he was
focused on the American people as
opposed to necessarily the gamesmanship
that that was being played in the room
in the clips that you just mentioned uh
you know the president started his talk
by talking about with pride the
bipartisan work that has happened
between Democrats and Republicans we
passed together and historic
infrastructure law which is putting
billions of dollars on the streets of
America to repair our roads and bridges
and deal with things like laying
groundwork for for high-speed internet
in fact since the president passed the
bipartisan infrastructure law there are
20 000 projects that are already
underway the president talked about
bipartisanship is solving problems like
the need to have serious and and smart
gun safety laws that was bipartisan work
for the first time in a decade you know
what I think is taking that issue on
that vice president he laid out very
nicely what your Administration has
accomplished and did it in great detail
the thing is though the latest polls
show Americans still think the economic
policies are making their lives worse
that they don't feel better off what can
you do to get the message across we we
know the laundry list of all the things
that have accomplished but yet for some
reason for many people the message isn't
translating what do you say to that what
are you doing about it well well listen
I I think that we have to really
understand that we went through a an
historic
pandemic which resulted in the loss of
of almost a million over a million lives
people lost their jobs jobs they lost a
sense of normalcy children lost very
significant gaps in terms of their
educational process and the effects of
all of that linger we look at the price
of eggs or milk and we know that there's
still work to be done but that's the
point that the president was making is
that our Administration and he is the
leader of it is fully aware of that and
that's why we've done things like cap
the cost of insulin for seniors at 35
dollars a month because for too long
people who have diabetes in particular
are seniors have looked at either
bankruptcy or being able to to take care
of their basic health needs that's why
it is soon going to be the case because
of our leadership that the cost of
prescription medication for seniors will
be capped on an annual basis at two
thousand dollars a year this is why on
the issue of high-speed internet and
access we have brought down the cost of
thirty dollars a month from many Working
Families because they deserve to know
that we are actually presenting
solutions to some of the everyday
burdens that families face and that's
the work that is happening
clearly yeah all of us have more work to
be done on many many issues but that's a
whole other story let's talk about China
he touched on China very briefly but we
we have to talk about the balloon okay
we know the balloon was shot down but
your your Administration is still
getting a lot of pushback on why you
didn't shoot it down earlier when it was
on the west coast before it traveled all
across the country picking up who knows
what in hindsight do you all think well
maybe we should have taken action a
little earlier are you pleased with how
you handled it I think that the
president without any question and I
spend a lot of time with him in the Oval
Office when he sits behind that Resolute
desk making decisions about what is in
the best interest of the American people
and I wish people could see what I see
because he always has the well-being and
the safety of the American people first
and foremost in his mind we've been
clear about policy as it turned as it
relates to China first of all when
there's a violation of our sovereignty
such as the president described last
night
took the balloon down done but there is
also the president's leadership on the
broader issue of how we need to deal
with China and we've been very clear we
invite competition we don't seek
conflict or confrontation but we are
prepared to do what is necessary to
compete including another point the
president made last night which is Our
intention and our work that is about
bringing jobs back to America bringing
manufacturing back to America
strengthening America's Workforce
creating jobs many of which don't
require college education but they do
require training such as what ibw and
our apprenticeship programs through our
labor unions provide that's the kind of
work we're doing and I think the
president has been very focused and
clear about the priorities
you know last night Joe Biden supporter
said he had a great night that he was on
he was firing on all cylinders it's
being described as a soft launch for the
presidential campaign which leads me to
you because I want to know how you're
feeling your supporters are saying you
personally are taking a lot of incoming
will she be on the ticket will she not
be on the ticket she seems to be in a
damned if she does damned if she doesn't
situation how are you feeling about the
job these days that you're doing and
people's perception of you on the ticket
well let me first of all say as the
president has said he intends to run it
and if he does I'll be running with him
as it relates to the work of being vice
president listen I love the American
people I today for example I'm going to
be traveling to Atlanta Georgia to meet
with a bunch of college students about
the work we're doing on the climate
crisis we are doing again historic work
that's about creating jobs but also
investing in a clean energy economy
tomorrow I'm going to be in Minnesota
yesterday I convened a bunch of foreign
policy experts around an upcoming trip
my second trip to Munich Germany to
speak on behalf of the American people
at the Munich security conference
there's important good work that's
happening and I take the job very
seriously and I'm honored to serve
all right I I know you're very busy
Madam vice president but I think people
want to know are you feeling okay doing
okay but I'm doing I am doing
I do appreciate it Gail I appreciate it
thank you I'm doing quite well thank you
for asking
and one more thing before you go bless
you Tony one more thing Tony just
sneezed what do you think needs what do
you think needs to be done to stop to
figure out a way to handle classified
documents because it seems to be equal
opportunity screw-ups on both sides
well listen when we look at the the
nature of these documents they're
they're very serious and there are there
are very good rules and protocols in
place and I know that they are being
followed
all right thank you for your time Madam
president I know you've got a lot to do
good to be with you Gail thank you so
much thank you everyone always good to
see you